[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos de visual política creo
que la mayoría vais a estar de acuerdo
conmigo conseguir una democracia de
calidad no es una tarea nada pero que
nada fácil en nuestro mundo ahí sí
muchas democracias pero desgraciadamente
épocas de calidad evidentemente cuando
hablo de calidad me refiero un sistema
democrático que respete la libertad
individual la seguridad jurídica la
pluralidad política y todas estas cosas
y a lo largo de 35 años ha estado
haciendo cambio político y no en busca
de una democracia por ronald pues bien
entre otras muchos existe un principio
básico un principio que es esencial en
toda democracia de calidad y que no
suele gustar nada pero que absolutamente
nada a la mayoría de los políticos
estoy hablando ni más ni menos que de la
alternancia algo imprescindible para
evitar que una sola persona o un grupo
de ellas terminan convirtiendo las
instituciones a los gobiernos en su
rancho particular yo creo que la
democracia es un acto en el que se
respeta la libertad de las personas
de presión de movimiento de vida
director y aquí se está haciendo la
democracia es precisamente por este
motivo por lo que en muchos países
existe la limitación de mandatos nada es
tan peligroso como dejar permanecer
largo tiempo a un mismo ciudadano en el
poder el pueblo se acostumbra a
obedecerle y él a mandarlo de donde se
origina la usurpación y la tiranía simón
bolívar amigos tratar de impedir la
alternancia política a cualquier precio
es algo que se ha hecho desde siempre y
con cierta frecuencia en todo el mundo y
en los últimos años ha sido américa
latina' la región que ha visto como
muchos políticos se las han apañado de
una forma u otra para mantener el poder
a toda costa político es como daniela
ortega en nicaragua juan orlando
hernández en hondura o nicolás maduro en
venezuela pero hay otra forma de medir
la democracia por donde venezuela
también sale muy fortalecido la
democracia económica por ejemplo podemos
medir el presupuesto de venezuela y el
presupuesto de colombia ahora el último
actor en sumarse a esta lista parece
estar siendo el presidente de bolivia
evo morales y la pregunta que muchos se
hacen es esta la democracia boliviana en
peligro
qué es lo que está ocurriendo porque
está siendo tan polémica en la
candidatura de evo morales- atentos
[Música]
promesas y apego al poder
el 22 de enero del año 2006 evo morales
se convirtió con más del 50% de los
votos en el primer presidente indígena
en los 193 años de independencia de
bolivia su llegada al poder o lo hemos
contado aquí en visual político en un
vídeo que os dejo en la descripción y
también al final de este significó el
final de la exclusión política para la
mayoría de la sociedad boliviana de
hecho desde una perspectiva histórica
creo que se puede decir que la llegada
al poder de evo era inevitable
[Música]
el caso es que con su discurso de
izquierdas en contra del imperialismo
yanki en favor de la participación
política de los pueblos indígenas y la
nacionalización de los recursos
naturales
evo morales- se propuso liderar toda una
transformación del país una
transformación que contó un amplísimo
apoyo popular para lograr sus objetivos
el gobierno boliviano apostó por algo
que ha estado muy de moda en
latinoamérica durante los últimos años
cambiar la constitución algo que por
cierto también hizo con un amplísimo
apoyo popular porque lo cierto es que
elección tras elección
evo morales- arrasaba en las urnas
[Música]
pero volvamos a la constitución a la
constitución del propio morales y visto
lo visto vais a flipar porque esto es lo
que decía su artículo 168 el periodo de
mandato de la presidenta o del
presidente y de la vicepresidenta o del
vicepresidente del estado es de 5 años y
pueden ser reelectas o reelectos por una
sola vez de manera continua artículo 168
de la constitución boliviana está claro
verdad de forma continuada a una persona
sólo puede ejercer el cargo de
presidente durante dos mandatos y cada
mandato dura cinco años de esta forma
como evo se presentó a la reelección en
el año 2009 su tiempo de gobierno
debería haber concluido en 2014 verdad
son matemáticas básicas
[Música]
estado plurinacional ordinario social y
económicamente el socialismo comunitario
a partir de la promulgación de la nueva
constitución política del estado
pero un momento aquí algo que no me
cuadra es el año 2018
evo morales sigue en el poder y se va a
presentar a la reelección en las
elecciones de 2019 entonces qué diantres
ha ocurrido atentos
[Música]
la reelección indefinida
amigos esta es la historia de cómo un
hombre se enamoró del poder vamos a ver
la propia constitución de evo establecía
la alternancia como un principio
necesario en el funcionamiento
democrático pero nada más aprobarse la
nueva constitución ya empezaron los
problemas
evo dijo que a ver que el mandato
anterior no contaba porque se haya
producido bajo otra constitución que
como el estado boliviano se había
refundado había que poner el marcador en
cero a ver esto es un poco absurdo la
alternancia no se establece como un
castigo sino como una forma de evitar
que una persona esté demasiado tiempo en
el poder y si tú crees en ella y le
introduces en la constitución que tú
mismo has liderado pues no tendrás que
respetar no pues no nada de eso
el caso es que evo morales consiguió que
una controvertida sentencia del tribunal
constitucional le diera la razón según
esta sentencia evo había sido el
presidente de bolivia pero ahora lo
quería ser del estado plurinacional de
bolivia que no es lo mismo así que
podría gobernar durante dos mandatos
consecutivos
veis la diferencia de la noche a la
mañana bolivia la bolivia de siempre
había desaparecido esto es lo que
explica que evo se presentará a las
elecciones de 2009 y a la reelección en
2014 pero ahora sí que sí ya no podría
volver a presentarse y ojo porque esto
es algo que el propio devo ha dicho
muchas veces ha dicho que en 2019
dejaría todo este mundo de la política
para abrir un restaurante
pero pero esperad un momento porque si
eso del restaurante suena muy bien pero
seguir en el poder
amigos y su evolucionaba mucho pero que
muchísimo mejor
[Música]
así que en 2015 apenas un año después de
la reelección diputados afines al
presidente presentaron una propuesta de
reforma de la constitución de la nueva
constitución recién aprobada adivináis
para que pues ni más ni menos para que
el presidente y el vicepresidente
pudieran ser reelegido dos veces es
decir para que evo pudiera volver a
presentarse en 2019 sin embargo amigos
en esta ocasión el tiro le salió por la
culata la reforma así salió adelante en
el parlamento pero tenía que aprobarse
también mediante referéndum y hay
sorpresa
evo lo perdió
[Música]
usted está de acuerdo con la reforma del
artículo 168 de la constitución política
del estado para que la presidenta o
presidente y la vicepresidenta o
vicepresidente del estado puedan ser
reelectas o reelectos por dos veces de
manera continua pregunta del referéndum
constitucional de 2016 la pregunta era
clara y la respuesta aún más si o no si
a la reelección o no a la reelección y
amigos los bolivianos dijeron que no
pero llegados a este punto os hago una
pregunta que creéis que hizo evo morales
a aceptar el resultado del referéndum y
la constitución que él mismo había
liderado pues frío frío el líder
indígena el político que había prometido
devolver la soberanía al pueblo de
repente vino a decir que bueno que a ver
que el pueblo había sido manipulado que
tampoco había que tenerlo muy en cuenta
eso sí a pesar de todo una vez más
prometido respetar los resultados ahora
bien esta vez iba en serio o no iba en
serio pues no tampoco
aprovechando su control sobre las
instituciones precisamente lo que trata
de evitar la alternancia evo consiguió
algo inaudito el tribunal constitucional
plurinacional el órgano que tiene que
interpretar la norma fundamental en su
sentencia 84 barras 2017 declaró
inválidas partes de la propia
constitución para justificar tal medidas
ha recurrido el derecho internacional y
el tribunal constitucional se dedicó a
valorar e interpretar la convención
americana de derechos humanos la
jurisprudencia de la corte
interamericana todo menos la propia
constitución nacional
al final el resultado de todo este
experimento es que los artículos que
molestaban a evo morales- de su propia
constitución quedaron de facto derogados
y se consideró atentos a la reelección
indefinida ni más ni menos que como un
derecho humano
vamos que limitar los mandatos y exigir
alternancia es todo un atentado contra
los derechos humanos no si al final al
evo va a conseguir que el mismísimo
uribe apoye su régimen en fin en serio
porque no es ninguna broma que un
político pueda hacer y deshacer con las
instituciones lo que le dé la gana eso
es peligroso muy peligroso en bolivia el
artículo 168 no se ha drogado ni
modificado lo que ocurre es que ahora la
constitución boliviana tiene partes que
se cumplen y otras que no todo esto es
lo que ha desatado las protestas contra
esta deriva antidemocrática de evo
morales- dentro y fuera del país por
supuesto ante semejante espectáculo
varios miembros del tribunal electoral
han dimitido y han sido sustituidos por
quien pues por personas cercanas al
propio partido de evo morales de esta
forma finalmente el pasado 4 de
diciembre de 2018 este órgano aprobó la
candidatura de evo morales a la
presidencia ideal
garcía linera a la vicepresidencia nada
es tan peligroso como dejar permanecer
largo tiempo a un mismo ciudadano en el
poder el pueblo se acostumbra a
obedecerle y él a mandarlo de donde se
origina la usurpación y la tiranía simón
bolívar pero a un momento ya se lo que
alguno de vosotros está pensando pero
enrique vamos a ver al fin y al cabo va
a haber unas elecciones si los
bolivianos no le quieren pues que no le
voten verdad pues amigos esto tiene dos
problemas primero una democracia nunca
nunca puede consistir en una tiranía de
la mayoría sobre la minoría las
instituciones tienen que respetarse y
tienen que existir mecanismos que le
impidan a un político aferrarse al poder
mediante el uso de técnicas como el voto
clientelar la dependencia del gobierno
el control de los medios de comunicación
o simplemente la coacción el segundo
problema tiene precisamente mucho que
ver con la obsesión que evo morales ha
demostrado por el poder
en otras palabras hasta dónde está
dispuesto a llegar evo morales y su
partido el movimiento al socialismo el
más con tal de mantenerse en el poder
[Música]
llegó perdió el referéndum y aún así se
presenta ha movido cielo y tierra para
ser de nuevo candidato así que ahora la
pregunta es instar a acaso dispuesto a
perder las elecciones o por si acaso va
a optar en cambio por la estrategia de
ganar a cualquier costa me estoy
refiriendo a la estrategia que ha
mantenido en el poder a personajes como
nicolás maduro daniel ortega o juan
orlando hernández
vamos el pucherazo de toda la vida esta
es la pregunta que muchos se hacen en
bolivia y ojo porque lo que sí ha
conseguido evo morales además de ser el
político boliviano que más tiempo ha
estado en el poder es que las
instituciones de este país actúen a su
antojo bolivianos declaran a evo morales
como el nuevo dictador más de 150
organizaciones civiles acordaron
declarar a evo morales como dictador y
determinaron una agenda de actividades
en defensa de la democracia en fin
amigos aquí en visual política estaremos
muy pero que muy atentos a lo que ocurra
pero ahora turno para ti está de acuerdo
con que evo morales se presente a la
reelección déjame tu respuesta a los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
por cierto en un próximo vídeo vamos a
echar un vistazo a la bolivia que ha
construido evo morales durante todos
estos años al frente del país si no te
lo quieres perder ya lo sabes
no olvides suscribirte a visual política
y por supuesto si este vídeo te ha
resultado interesante echarnos una mano
dándole like amigos un saludo y hasta la
próxima
viviendo en el estado bolívar la
videncia
el estado plurinacional ordinario social
económicamente el socialismo comunitario